[Music]
Nellie was arrested for alleged sexual
assault et has learned that the 42 year
old rapper was taken into custody early
Saturday morning for allegedly sexually
assaulting a woman on his tour bus in
Washington according to a press release
issued by the Auburn Police Department
the alleged incident happened just hours
after Nellie performed at the White
River amphitheater in a statement to ET
Nellie's lawyer says the allegations are
completely fabricated quote our initial
investigation clearly establishes this
allegation is devoid of credibility and
is motivated by greed and vindictiveness
adding that once the accusations are
thoroughly investigated he is confident
there will be no charges Nellie also
took to Twitter to share his side of the
story and apologized to his loved ones
for the embarrassment writing I am
completely innocent
he later shared to be absolutely clear I
have not been charged with the crime
therefore no bail was required
I was released pending further
investigation the singer is currently on
tour with Florida Georgia line
[Music]
you